unlv's president breaks his silence
doing his first interview with the
i-team after a fraternity boxing match
resulted in a student's death i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis it is a
story the i-team first broke one week
ago vanessa murphy tells us what unlv
leaders are now saying and how the
university is handling this tragedy
unlv president keith whitfield says a
review is underway about the fraternity
boxing match what the i-team has been
working to find out is what knowledge
the university had before the event was
held what oversight did the university
have and what leaders at the university
did know this was going to happen
that's one of the questions that we're
asking in this fact-finding
let's not call an investigation it's a
review of our procedures that we want to
go through
not only for this group but for all
programs on our campus nathan valencia a
20-year-old unlv junior participated in
this fraternity boxing match for charity
on november 19th he collapsed after the
fight and died four days later from head
injuries weigh-in was held on campus for
the boxers and the event held by the
kappa sigma fraternity took place off
campus is there someone at unlv who
oversees fraternities
fraternities
that falls under our student affairs and
there are advisors that are connected
with each one of the fraternities and
there's other work as well that's done
by other people in that division
valencia's parents say there was a lack
of safety precautions they say the
referee wasn't a professional ref the
i-team obtained this video showing him
drinking what appears to be alcohol and
frequently looking at the judge's table
witnesses tell the i-team no paramedics
were on standby the valencia family also
points out this was a unlv tradition
should this event have been held in the
first place weigh-in was held on campus
and should it ever be held again
you know we're going to make that
decision after we've gone through all of
this because
one of the things that we try to do is
to actually support and promote students
having activities and doing things we
also spoke with chancellor melody rose
she heads nevada's system of higher
education and says responsibility falls
on unlv rather than her office the
president's office oversees student
affairs
student activities student athletics and
we do have a role in policy making
and i think when we are beyond this
conversation and results of an
investigation come through
i think at that point you you could see
a policy conversation at the board of
regents did you personally know that
these events had happened in years past
and did you know this one was going to
be held
no i was not aware
of the history of this event nor was i
aware that this particular event was
scheduled as the leader of this
university who do you think should be
held accountable
well you know it's premature to say
exactly who we
want to
to start pointing fingers on about
accountability we're going to do a very
very thorough process and we're going to
make sure that we identify all the parts
and pieces of how this played out at
this point it is unknown when that
review may be finished reporting in las
vegas vanessa murphy live local now